now would you guys say it at your
standard work week 20 hours the 40 hours
a week is that is that generally how you
guys roll 40 hours a week who does that
when you try to do this you can't know
it's how many hours is it if you do it
all the time and you only give yourself
like two or three hours of sleep that's
about where we're at hey what were you
saying again like I always tell like
always took Chris the only time I'm
going to rest I'm not sleeping right now
the only time going to sleep it's when
i'm dead in the ground that's when I
rest right now I'm gonna be awake and
I'm beyond in computers sending them you
know life is a literary life is to be
live i'm not gonna go to sleep right now
because when people take advantage of
their life you know I merely sleeping
like 20 hours a day the next time the
day I'll sleep is when I'm dead and gone
and buried that's it right now I'm up
and I'm gonna be up and doing what I did
doing what I love to do basically so
yeah it's constant I mean you can't you
can't take breaks in there so I mean you
know everybody has the day job you know
you know well some people are lucky
enough to have the day job actually be
their passion but for me it's not there
yet so I work I work my day job and
after that you know the moment the clock
ticks it's like Street films time and I
do that and I try to live by the mantle
if I'm gonna put in eight hours or on
the grind you know then I'll put in
eight hours on my passion and I live by
that you know every day and as a writer
I try to write a scene a day if I can
you know that was my thing is uh you
know you do a see today you're gonna
have a script done in about two months
and I did all that that's my thing is
you know give whether it's a good one
another's right but you will
consistently work and you will
consistently be able to craft the
product and get to that final version of
the script if you just touch it every
single day and you give it its due and I
earn my sleep I don't earn I don't just
get up and say oh yeah it's time to go
to that I earn it and how do i earn it I
do what I have to do and then I do what
I want to do and I make sure they equal
you know I make sure they match so if i
do eight hours on my day job and do
eight hours on Lake Street films and
then I've earned the right to put my
head on the pill
for a little while and you know that's
kind of how I get through it
you